[Musique]
contrairement à ce que vous pourriez
croire ce tableau en oeuvre collective
des deux petites ne me représente pas il
représente une panthère naturellement
vous vous demandez où delphine et
marinette ont pu voir une panthère je
vais vous raconter cette histoire si
vous permettez
et même si vous ne permettez pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais mal fonction qui peut le rester
alors certes tendu la chine
c'est un pays où tout le monde à la tête
jaune et les yeux [ __ ] à bien quelques
japon c'est un pays où tout le monde a
la tête sous les yeux [ __ ] elle
différente at il entre la chine et japon
ya aucune différence entre la chine et
japon
qu'est ce que vous faites les petites
bagarres centenaire vois tu es ce que
vous apprenez notre géographie
qu'est ce que c'est la géographie salon
du pays
il y à beaucoup de pays beaucoup trop
canard au lieu d'apprendre les pays dans
le livre on ferait mieux de les
apprendre sur place ce serait plus
fatigant moi je me sent une envie de
voyager si vous saviez tu veux nous
quitter les dauphins heureux avec nous
si il y à personne que j'aime autant que
vous par exemple je n'en dirais pas
autant de vos parents voyez vous je me
demande s'ils ont du coeur
je parie que tu penses à notre vieux
cheval on y pense aussi mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut pas je parie vous étiez en
train de parler de moi oui justement on
disait tout à fait quelques donc tu
l'avais bien millions be vous êtes
gentille et je voudrais vous croire et
lâche aux parents ne sont pas de votre
avis ils disent que je suis trop vieux
et que je ne gagne pas ma nourriture non
cheval tu te fais des idées aux
logements encore toute ma tête
la preuve de ce que je dis et ce matin
nous parents voulaient me vendre à la
boucherie
finalement ils ont pensé que je pouvais
encore rendre des services pendant l'été
ils ont décidé de me vendre à la foire
de septembre
qu'est ce que cette grille ans fait la
vraie mais d'aller brouter pour garder
un peu de force
ça fait cinq minutes de pro à
on aurait dû la vente ce matin ben toi
qu'un art qu'est ce que tu fais là
j'étais venu dire mon soir au petit
excusez moi voilà un canard qui se porte
le joli nom d' vraiment fait plaisir
regardez ça me fait penser que l' oncle
alfred galets jeu dès dimanche
en entendant cette remarque les petites
devine air que le canard ne verrait le
dimanche suivant que du fond d'une
casserole mais aussi le pré certes elle
de réaliser ses projets de voyage avant
cette triste échéance un mât longueur du
mississippi et de 3780 km la longueur de
la mare de la ferme six mètres à peu
près c'est fatigant la géographie mais
j'aime encore mieux ça que le fond d'une
casserole
[Applaudissements]
finalement ils partis le vendredi
un jour un dieu canard ne soit pas trop
d'autos absorbe ne nous oublie pas bon
rivage et le canard partie d'un bon pas
sans se retourner au garage trois rivaux
il traversa un grand nombre de pays mais
tin particulièrement à visiter le
bengale il avait en effet rencontré un
jour un habitant et l'est de ce pays un
oiseau nommait bengali qui s'était
échappé de sa cage
le plumage de cet oiseau n'avait d'égal
que son ramage et ils avaient tous deux
et bluewin autres canards c'est un beau
pays mais on ne voit pas grand monde
les petites m'ont pourtant raconté que
c'était une région surpeuplée
pendant que je suis ici il faudrait que
je trouve un souvenir rapporté au petit
appart à qu'est ce que c'est que ça je
suis un canard de france et moi une
faute en chanter pas tant que moi c'est
l'heure du déjeuner pour m'inviter à
déjeuner en quelque sorte
moi je comprends vous n'avez pas honte
j'ai honte mais j'ai faim au lieu d'un à
penser qu'à manger vous feriez lieu de
changer à vous instruire
je parie que vous ne savez même pas
comment s'appelle votre pays est bien à
fond dès que vous vivez au bengale dont
les habitants s'appellent des bengalis
industries principal feu de bagarre
c'est merveilleux la géographe
si vous voulez je vous apprendrai tout
ce que je sais la panthère accepta de
grand coeur et sans perdre un instant le
canard lui a pris tout ce qu'il savait
et même un peu plus car il n'est pas
nécessaire de ne savoir que la vérité
l'océan pacifique est ainsi nommé à
cause de ces terribles tempêtes il y a
deux pôles le nord et le sud
mais comme ils sont aussi froid là que
l'autre ne vois pas l'intérêt et la
panthère fut si reconnaissante aux
canards de ces leçons qu'elle décida de
le suivre de venir à la ferme avec lui
[Musique]
le cahors
n'ayez pas peur c'est mon ami la
panthère
ce coton salut les amis de mes amis sont
mes amis vous attendez bien que je te
présente au petit ça fait longtemps que
le canard est parti à temps fou oui au
moins qui est là quand on parle du
canard angoisse accueil j'ai fait un
beau voyage
je vous raconterai plus tard mais je ne
reviens pas seul
jeudi marion brioude non mais j'ai
ramené une amie ou jouent
n'ayez pas peur
[Musique]
le canard m'a bien souvent parler de
vous
c'est comme si je vous connaissais déjà
vous êtes dans notre livre d'histoire
naturelle est ce votre photographie la
panthère est une mangeuse de 22
personnes
je ne le ferai plus le canard m'a appris
la géographe
il va par rapport à la science adoucit
les moeurs
je me porte garant de sa sincérité nous
sommes rentrés applique du bengale la
panthère maman j'ai eu des carottes ou
alors de mauvaises espèces comme les
rats les mulots et autres ronge
j'espère que vous dites vrai n'ont pas
non plus alors comment trouvez-vous
notre pays il est bien agréable
je suis sûr que je me plairait et
maintenant donnez moi des nouvelles du
vieux cheval dont le canard m'a parlé
car il m'a parlé de tout le monde
je n'ai pas vu dans la cour il est en
train de pleurer dans l'écurie
nos parents ont décidé le mans et demain
la boucherie je vais arranger ça faites
moi confiance je peux entrer peut
repasser par la peau si vous bougez je
vous met en pièces
qu'est-ce qu'on vienne me dire que vous
allez vendre votre vieux cheval à la
boucherie auront vous n'avez pas honte
une pauvre bête qui a passé toute sa vie
à travailler pour vous je ne sais pas ce
qui me retient de mouvement
que vous avez raison nous garderons le
cheval j'ai appris aussi que vous aviez
privé les petites de desserts pendant
huit jours pour avoir pris la défense du
cheval oh je vous préviens qu'avec moi
ça va changer
pour commencer je lève la punition des
petites mémés wa vous ronchonner non
et la panthère par là encore d autres
bêtes que de la ferme exigent qu'elles
soient cajoler qu'elle meurt tout de
leur bonne mort mais le ton de ces
paroles de vins moins sévère
et comme elle a ajouté qu'elle ne
demandait que le bonheur général les
parents se rassurent air l'accueillir
d'assez bon coeur et s'habitue air vite
à sa présence elle rendit d'ailleurs
bientôt des services la nuit
particulièrement gdc fin des chiffres un
peu plus on voit je me ferais un festin
je peux vendre sa part une ou deux voies
la ja et comme plat de résistance
je vois si bien un mouton et à ses nuits
maintenant elle aussi et la panthère
faisait aussi les cours se porter les
lettres à la poste le tout quatre fois
plus vite que le cheval le plus rapide
enfin elle jouer avec tout le monde les
parents les petites et les animaux de la
ferme
c'était l'âge d'or tout simplement les
bêtes ville est en sécurité et les gens
neutres et n'est plus comme autrefois le
remords de les manger
les parents avaient perdu l'habitude de
crier et de menacer et le travail était
devenu pour tout le monde un plaisir et
cela durera jusqu'à une certaine partie
de quatre coins
jeantet non tu m'a fallu six shows tels
lan a raison il ya eu un chat vous
regarde je suis larbitre et je te boe
d'abord je t'interdis de me tutoyer
alors je vous ordonne de vous considérer
comme or moi j'ai envie de vous dire un
gros mot faites attention si je me fonde
alors je joue peu j'aime bien jouer aux
quatre coins mais je veux pas en passer
par les caprices des étrangères je ne
sais pas ce que je lui ferais moi ou si
vous m'énervez je vais aller faire un
tour pour me calmer
où je vais en faire autant à la fin de
l'après-midi la panthère entra alors ça
va mieux sourire et tu as l'air d'avoir
sobel c'est que j'aime beaucoup
on dirait aussi que toi gros ventre
c'est de la dilatation l'estomac
le cochon lui était pas encore rentrés
ils ne devraient pas perdu mais en fin
d'après-midi le cochon n'était toujours
pas là
[Musique]
tu es plus grosse que d'habitude et ton
ventre et loup comme si tu avais trop
mangé dans les bois je me suis laissé
aller à dévorer deux marcassins ce n'est
pas bien grave
non ce n'est pas bien grave d'ailleurs
les sangliers alimli récolte un mois la
panthère m'a dit qu'elle avait
dilatation des stops a par conséquent
aux italiens annoncent en joue et nous
en a dit un hamilton ait menti à tout le
monde
elle sera querellé avec le cochon et
pour se venger elle aura mangé dans un
coin je ne suis pas seul à m'être
querellé avec lui il a un caractère de
cochon et se dispute avec tout le monde
et s'il a été mangée pourquoi serait ce
pas comme si tout le monde ne mangeait
pas de cochon à commencer par vous les
petites combien en avez-vous déjà mangé
nous parlons plus espérons que le cochon
viendra il était parti en voyage comme
le ghana le total ou vinci
oui tout par des cochons d'inde
mais le cochon ne devait jamais revenir
qu'il fut parti en voyage paraît bien
improbable
il avait peu d'imagination et préféré à
l'aventuré
une vie bien réglée quant à croire que
la panthère l'avaient mangé c'est une
autre affaire en tout cas la disparition
du cochon n'empêcha pas la vie de
reprendre à la ferme
l'oubli est commun aux bété aux gens on
se remit à jouer aux quatre coins fait
[Musique]
et même il faut bien le dire ont joué
beaucoup mieux depuis que le cochon nous
n'était plus là
aa je sens qu'il va pleuvoir
ouais il commence à ne plus faire chaud
voici l'hiver et son triste cortège mais
c'était le premier hiver que vous voyez
la panthère son pays natal le bas galles
connaissait un éternel été et de ce fait
bien sûr elle ignorait ce qu'était le
froid je ne comprends pas ce qui se
passe dehors ça arrive tous les ans
l'hiver et quand c'est l'hiver il fait
froid
oui mais c'est bon pour ma campagne si
votre univers est bon pour la campagne
elle ne devrait pas être triste
dans mon pays quand il pleut on voit
pousser les feuilles les arbres à vue
d'oeil tout devient plus vert ici la
plus froid tout est triste tout ça kiabi
turin et puis la pluie ne durera pas
toujours
bientôt il y aura de la neige tu verras
comme ses gains et jolie est ce que
c'est c'est un duvet blanc 5 magie de
cannes à qui répondre je voudrais mais à
voir il fallut attendre quelques
semaines
mais un matin enfin tous furent couverts
de neige et la panthère qui était de
plus en plus triste est frileuse bondi
dehors
[Musique]
j'ai fait attention de ne pas prendre
froid
moi j'ai demandé une couverture ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais faire une grande
promenade et elle couru pendant des
heures et des heures puis la fatigue
arriva avec la nuit alors elle voulu
rentrer mais la neige et le froid
l'empêcheur de retrouver le chemin du
retour elle marcha encore vainement et
finalement se couchant dans la neige
glacée
la panthère n'est pas rentré du super
dans la neige il faudra la chercher
demain matin elle retrouvèrent la
panthère après de longues recherches est
très loin de la ferme le bel animal
grelottait ses membres étaient déjà
raide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien froid nous allons te
réchauffer et te soigner c'est trop tard
un ter faut pas mourir
pantech tinh où quelque chose c'est moi
qui ai mangé le cochon men augmenté
[Musique]
on